it is done
Elon Musk has closed his deal it has
been reported he said he bought the
platform there may be some subtleties
and some Nuance over the next day or so
but uh apparently it's done I guess when
Elon Musk walked in with the kitchen
sink that was him being like it's mine
he showed up this is really funny viral
photo of an angry looking Twitter
employee who's like like staring at him
but uh it is what it is now here's the
big news Tesla Engineers have entered
Twitter HQ to do a code review
oh please please please I'm so excited
for this I hope whatever they got
working in in in the machine all this
garbage and Gunk I hope Elon just comes
out and says hey remember when Jack
Dorsey said all those things he was
lying here look at this code look what
we found and it's like all of it comes
out but hey you know maybe maybe he
released the code and there's nothing
overtly nefarious in there but I think
what we're going to see is the bias
intentional or otherwise they're going
to be like hey look at these key for
these phrases that were banned or
filtered or Shadow band this is going to
be interesting if Elon Musk actually
actually stays true to his word so we'll
talk about that there's a lot of stories
here the left they're fleeing to tribal
social who pre-banned Donald Trump
hilarious they say we don't censor
anything we just filter hate speech and
fake news and the fake news coincides
with actual real news but you know they
can't have their narrative interrupted
so we'll talk about that plus a hot mic
catches Chuck Schumer saying we're in
danger I Love It Ralph Wiggum meme the
Democrats are going to lose and it's so
bad that one Democratic consultant
thinks that Ron DeSantis is going to win
Miami-Dade County that is a major urban
center whoa before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work we're gonna have an
awesome members only uncensored show
coming up for you tonight at 11 PM you
don't want to miss it and as a member
you're supporting our journalists we've
got field reporters people on the ground
covering stuff we've got we've fact
check all day every day a great team of
people who are reporting on the news and
it's thanks to you we're able to keep
this up but don't forget we got cast
Castle we got Tales from the inverted
World new shows coming so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to discuss this and more is
Alex bruceowitz how you doing guys who
are you here I'm Alex Bruce Woods I like
long walks on the beach
um do you really though no I actually
hate the beach sand is horrible but I
own a consulting company called X
strategies we work with America First
candidates all over the country we're
really looking forward to a lot of wins
on November 8th so uh we like to make
America great again over here right on
and while normally uh I would shout out
the T-shirt Merchant in fact we also
have a pillow Merchant
well actually uh I this is Ian Crossland
as you can all tell
um for those of you listening on the
podcast version obviously my voice has
not changed in any way because this is
definitely Ian Crossland get your
graphene whoa that was really weird Ian
just kind of like channeled my my mind
for a secondary he's downstairs yeah
he's downstairs meditating doing his uh
his some people do one arm push-ups he
does armless push-ups I don't know
only when he's playing Magic only yeah
well it depends on what is what his Mana
is at the time uh but no Jack was so big
what's up promo code poso at
mypillow.com and other various sundry
websites uh human events daily we're
just killing it over there and uh huge
shout out to just everybody for asking
me to come on I've been trying to come
on pretty much all season but been a
little busy just got back from Louisiana
we're up in Erie Pennsylvania
campaigning with the great Doug
mastriano who was fantastic here it was
cool dude the other night uh and much
much better than John fetterman who as
Michael malice has looked like if
someone Chewbacca wow
my name is
a little bit of a complicated t-shirt
that I have on today it has Facebook
saying I delete your post Amazon's
saying I delete your books YouTube's
saying I delete your videos and then of
course we have Mr Bill Gates saying I
delete you and then underneath that is
of course Elon Musk this was this was an
original shirt just with Bill Gates at
the end of it we just added Elon Musk
saying I revive the deleted if you like
the shirt you could get it on the best
political shirts because you do I am
here
and I am sir Dupree hello guys you know
I'm I'm it's like the one night I don't
have a sponsor we don't often do reads
and I'm like I wish I had something
because you know Jack's shouting out
pillows Luke's shouting out shirts and
I'm just like we need vitamins or
something we need some kind of like
traditional podcast boxer brief or
something but I guess we don't have so
we'll just settle with with the promo
code Pozo and boom and Luke's shirts
Luke's also set up his shirts in such a
way that you actually have to read down
lower and lower and lower I know what
I'm doing let's get the joke so there's
a lot of uh there's a lot of subliminal
stuff going on there all right ladies
and gentlemen here's the big news from
today Elon Musk releases statement
explaining Twitter purchase quote it is
important to the future of civilization
to have a common digital Town Square
where a range of beliefs can be debated
in a healthy manner without resorting to
violence and of course he is correct
um you know he said some some
interesting things there that he's he's
trying to bring people together and I
think Elon might be a little bit naive
let me tell you guys a story I recently
went to um
I was in Texas and I got to meet with a
bunch of people including uh some
confidants and Associates of Elon I
guess I'm here as a party and so people
who were there claim to know him I don't
know but there were a lot of influential
people there who worked in the tech
sector and it was a big Tech sector
thing and then I just I was there and I
said to my I was I was talking to some
friends and I was like I don't think
these guys understand culture at all
they very much understand technology and
that's probably why Elon wanted to buy
Twitter in the first place because he
understands his power but he does not
understand the left he really doesn't I
think he's relatively new to this so
Aiden paladin on Twitter I saw this
great thing that uh she had posted
numerous studies show that inherent in
the left explicitly and overtly
it is dominated by greed violence Envy
hatred and there's numerous studies that
she cited in this post showing all of
these scientific studies about how
that's where they're rooted I'm not
surprised because we get fake news we
get manipulation we get lying cheating
stealing it's remarkable when when uh
when a commercial played today I'm
skating we have the radio on well we
have Pandora on and they just they're
lying about Dr Oz and I'm like look I
don't like Oz but it's all lies you know
why the defamation lawsuit cost of doing
business to win an election you lie
about your opponent you win the packs
got to pay a fee that's just part of the
part of the process I don't think Elon
Musk understands the bifurcation of
culture and where this ultimately will
lead to but I will say when it comes to
this escalating conflict the right
continually being like we will let the
left speak we just want to speak to and
we don't want to fight we want peaceful
divorce that's when you get crushed yeah
when you have two sides fighting and or
or really when you have two groups and
and I know that there's sort of been
this
description of American societies left
versus right left versus right left
versus right and I don't think that's
correct I don't actually think that's
right at all I think there's the left I
think there's the right and in the
middle you have normies I oh hold on and
there you know certainly there's other
groups out there it's a spectrum Etc but
normies are the people who are like not
focused on politics not focused on news
24 7 they're not the junkies they're not
going in for that dopamine fix on
Twitter on YouTube whatever all the time
and so the question is are the normies
getting more and more radicalized or not
are they getting are they paying
attention are they getting red pilled
but then when you have one group that
says we are going to destroy you and
change all of culture to fit our needs
and fit our culture and our precepts and
another side that says hey we just want
to be left alone then it's pretty
obvious which side's gonna win I I want
to just I don't I don't know if it's
left right nor me I used to think that
now what I think happened is you have
the left and the right and then a weird
growth on the left started to Bubble Up
and then schlocked off and has become
this weird
unhinged hateful chaotic destructive
force that thinks it's the left and then
looks at the normal world of Left Right
and moderate as right wing that's why
everyone to the right of Stalin is far
right they called did you see Jezebel
called the Ian Crossland a conservative
commentator I mean he's just the most
conservative guy I mean he's always here
demanding traditional marriage telling
people to stop getting divorced yeah you
need to raise that baby no no they
mistakenly uh they were referring to a
quote from Sheamus but just the fact
that they they didn't even realize the
mistake I mean all white people look
alike so I to them I suppose but I think
about that I think about when they say
like Tim Poole is far right and I'm like
it's just so weird that I'm like this
traditional liberal and you know like
Jack you're conservative Luke's you're
an anarchist Alex I believe you're
conservative too and we're having civil
discussion with Ma moderate American
culture styled disagreements in in the
space and agreements and whatever this
weird left that troughed off
just doesn't believe in anything at all
and the Democrats try to Pander to that
that you you're it's like it's a sludge
it's also it's also that it's not that
they don't believe in anything it's that
what they believe is not a political
ideology what they believe is a form of
political theocracy
yeah the sludge also is so effective
because they've moved together and
they're always the loudest people in the
rooms they're always there to they're
they're the mob and they try to shout
you down it's fire and and beat you up
and Elon is facing that daily now on
Twitter uh you know before look at the
photos you saw the photos right when he
went to see when he went to visit
Twitter today the woman's face yeah and
you can see the people that he's talking
to right whoever he's making eye contact
with and you can see because there were
a variety of photos that came out not
just this one I was I haven't seen any
videos yet which is weird like why do we
have photos but not video and whenever
he's making eye contact with someone
he's a Charming guy obviously he's very
personable
um they're super nice but then when he
turns you always get these photos behind
like yeah I mean I think it's also
important to assess here that Elon Musk
did buy Twitter because of what you guys
are describing there's a meeting going
around today of uh uh The Dominoes
falling and one of them is the Babylon
bee calling a man a man being a very
small Domino and then the very big
Domino at the end is Elon Musk walking
into Twitter headquarters with a kitchen
sink in his hands good yeah so so I I
think I think the letter to advertisers
that Elon Musk wrote Today is extremely
telling he wrote about how he was doing
this for Humanity he wrote about how big
Tech social media is bifurcating
splintering people to the far left and
the far right he talked about Echo
Chambers he talks about how he wants to
help Humanity with this purchase as this
letter looks like he's laying the
groundwork for allowing people that were
previously deleted back on the platform
which is going to create some
controversy it looks like he's trying to
save face from the controversy it looks
like he's setting up a situation where
he's like making the argument for
bringing back free speeches
it's been reported that he closed the
deal yeah he's in Twitter HQ
why isn't James O'Keefe back on the
platform no no hold on I know everyone
immediately says Tim Alex Jones Donald
Trump I'm like I understand all of those
those are political arguments the
argument with say Jones and with Trump
and Carl Benjamin uh is you know oh well
uh hate speech or whatever and then we
roll our eyes and say that's ridiculous
James O'Keefe broke no rules
they didn't even what was it they said
he was operating multiple accounts for
some fake reason I think they did the
same thing to Milo as well like the
first thing Elon should have done when
he walked in
is said like okay we we seriously need
to like Veritas back on the platform
yeah well I I have a feeling it's going
to look a lot like the Pokemon movie
when like all of the Pokemon like turned
to stone and then Ash starts crying and
you know all of a sudden the Pokemon
come back to life that's what Twitter's
gonna be the first time I've ever heard
anyone actually make a Pokemon movie the
Pokemon well that's what it's gonna be
it's gonna be an awesome scene
everyone's gonna be moved to tears from
Narnia isn't that the end of Lion The
Witch in the wardrobe I don't know this
this movie came out they might have they
might have but it was in the 1940s yeah
and then uh and then Mewtwo I'm not a
historian Jack and then Mewtwo says I
understand now the circumstances of
one's birth does not define you okay
okay exactly stop nerding out wait here
let's talk about this jeans O'Keefe
Mewtwo or is Alex Jones Mewtwo no I
think James O'Keefe is like probably the
guy just standing there filming what's
going on they kicked out
he's the camera guy from Jack dorsey's
Mewtwo no oh that's both no that's
Pokemon Snap that's different stop it
stop it we have to talk about what's
really going on here no no TMZ is
reporting that that Elon Musk is
officially a buyer of Twitter from the
reports that I'm looking at right now
the bank accounts are still sending the
money uh to all the people that are the
shareholders they're still in the
process I didn't get paid and Elon Musk
Where's My Money Elon again I mean he's
known for doing rash things but I think
in this huge billion dollar investment
that that is taking away a quarter of
his entire wealth I think he's going to
be smart but also slow I think he's
going to be looking at what happened
looking at each case individually and I
think if anyone's going to be reinstated
first I think it's going to be the
Babylon B for sure I I I think you know
so I have 22 shares with Twitter and I
see the price at like 54 bucks now it's
like 53 or something they're delisting
it from the New York Stock Exchange
which basically confirms the deals done
and uh Elon I want my money where's my
money I'll tell you what I will only
accept the money in the form of you
coming here personally and sitting down
and then you know handing the cash while
the show is on of course so so tomorrow
at 8pm uh eastern time is the only time
I'm accepting the cash there's a love to
see you there's a line and I'm gonna
paraphrase it from Machiavelli's the
prince
um you know 500 years old but everybody
remembers it where he says that if a
prince must commit atrocities he should
commit them early
[Laughter]
and and so I always kind of think of
that that Elon has this sort of period
right now where what I'm calling for
don't do this piecemeal this like set up
some system of well we'll do this one
we'll do Babylon we'll no blanket
amnesty yeah
overturn every single permanent band on
Twitter make everyone when they come
back they hold on hold on they have to
redo their terms of service they have to
sign up again they have to go through
the process they have to follow it but
my point is release the release the
prisoners of war from the great meme war
of 2015 2016 immediately let my people
go hold on hold on there's a challenge
there there are a lot of accounts that
were permanently banned for things we
would agree they should be banned for
like graphic images of kids or uh well
you set up a system where if if it's not
something that's directly criminal for
example uh as Elon has said if it's on
the First Amendment then I'm going to
let it on I I do think they're uh
I I agree mostly I do I just think it
has to be it can't be a blanket it has
to be a probably a large analysis they
need to be able to go and look at
however they went about banning them and
like if anyone banned for saying learn
to code reinstated instantly for example
we already know and he hates speech ban
we know through the Missouri lawsuit
with uh A.G Schmidt that they were
Banning people at the behest of the NIH
they were Banning people on the behest
of uh the White House California the
White House
um DC draino got banned because the
state of California we know that
um what I'm thinking of Alec Berenson
Alec Berenson was able to get his
account back because he pointed out the
Twitter instituted this three-strike law
for covid-19 and then they didn't even
follow their own three strikes which
also gets to my point because that's
contract law that right you need to fix
the terms of service but it kind of take
the discussion back up a little bit I I
think that what you said at the
beginning really is the biggest part
here the fact that these Tesla coders
are coming in these Engineers are
looking at this let's pull it up I mean
this is Neo inside the Matrix now let me
here's a story from Bloomberg Tesla
Engineers visit Twitter office to review
code for Musk
well there you go I mean that's the news
this is so
um
I I think this is why the Jag got it was
crying when the news broke that Elon was
buying the platform because I wonder
who's going to prison
well I think wow people should certainly
be held accountable and face serious
consequences for what Twitter did
especially during the 2020 election uh
you know leading up to the 2020 election
when they censored the hunter Biden
story and they started banning all the
conservative counts and out of nowhere
they banned political advertising
without giving people really much of a
heads up and there should be some real
life consequences for this Facebook by
the way has just been ordered to pay
24.7 million dollars to the state of
Washington because they didn't release
all the information behind their
political advertisements now imagine
what we're going to see if we're going
to actually see anything because again
at the end of the day we also have to
start thinking about this this way this
is Elon musk's new product will he
release information that makes this
product look bad that's another question
I think we should be asking ourselves it
could make it look good look because
it's all you're also looking at the
regime change if Elon comes in right now
and says just right at the gate
so when they testified before Congress
about these three things they lied
here's the proof in their code I wonder
who then you know if they they I don't
know if they testified under oath or
whatever probably not but that'll be
huge make Twitter look as bad as
possible and that's that's the right
move you know why because then if in two
years you only make it look a little bit
better it looks a lot better you know
what I mean when when uh when Chairman
Mao died in 1976
um the party the Chinese Communist Party
of course they have their new emperor
now but at the time they realized they
had to CR they had to kind of find a way
to maintain the legitimacy of the party
in the face of the cultural revolution
15 million people have been killed every
school every University in the entire
country shut down families turned
against family it's abject chaos going
on across the entire country so they
have to find some way to say okay we can
still be in power we have to maintain
the brand but we have to separate from
this so what do they do they blamed it
on his wife
and three of her friends they call him
the gang of four they arrested the wife
then she commits suicide in prison
um and and then Deng Xiaoping the party
go off and and say well now that we've
taken care of that everything's fine
take a look at this in the story they
say Twitter's Engineers can no longer
make changes to code AS of noon in uh
San Francisco with people wow that's
part of an effort to ensure that nothing
about the product changes ahead of the
deal closing so the people who decline
to be named come on they had months to
figure out how to cover their tracks and
and bury the evidence right they
probably called in Hillary Clinton be
like Hillary Clinton you got experience
please or bring the hard drive please I
mean this is this is bring the rag if
Sheamus is listening we got one for you
Elon is going to buy the platform and
and then Vijaya got if it's crying what
do we do they're gonna get the evidence
and then they hear a doorbell ring and
they open the door and it's Hillary
Clinton with like six hammers in her
belt and she's like let's go and
sunglasses smashing everything with
hammers uh and for those who don't know
it's because the Clinton campaign
smashed their phones with hammers
thinking that would actually stop
someone from collecting the data but you
know and when she was asked at one point
about wiping her server her legal email
server that she had in her bathroom she
said was in my bathroom yeah yeah she
said right you mean like with a rag yes
and then I love when NBC News Trump said
she she acid washed her server it was
like fact check false Hillary Clinton
did not use a corrosive wait you
remember how they called the guy on
Reddit right yeah yeah yeah he's
bragging about it well no no he wasn't
just bragging he didn't know how to do
it he went and he said how do I remove a
very very VIP from some emails
and I'd also like to point out that
yesterday was the six year anniversary
of Hillary Clinton's happy birthday to
the Future president yes uh the tweet
that will forever live in infamy one of
the greatest tweets ever in my opinion
I'd just like to sometimes Play that
video where she's sitting in the chair
and she's like you can be the candidate
you can be the nominee and it can be
stolen from you and then I'm just like
uh see well she doubled down on those uh
elect being an election denier a couple
days ago she said that right-wing
extremists are already starting to steal
the 2024 election and you know I just
got subpoenaed and went through a year
and a half of you know health or
questioning the legitimacy of the 2020
election with evidence backing it up you
know is a republican Congress going to
subpoena Hillary Clinton for sowing
distrust in the 2024 election already so
you know the wicked witch is refusing
but by the way look listen to these
these phrases that we're using now
sowing distrust raising questions
none of there's no law backing up any of
these things there's this isn't a legal
basis the legal basis in the United
States is something called freedom of
speech did you see the Veritas that's
where the sludge comes from you see the
project Veritas release that said uh
yeah they're tracking misinformation as
an election crime and they Define it as
accidental like false information it's
like a mistake so it's like I mean there
used to be an old joke and I'm not going
to say it but the this whole joke that
you know they would say republican vote
on and then they would use a different
day of the week than election day or you
could change it and say Democrats vote
on a different you see what I'm saying
yeah and that would be this idea
got arrested for that there was a there
was a guy who was well we just saw uh
over over a draft Meme and he was
arrested and charged claiming you know
this this meme campaign that was done in
2016 it was I believe it started on
4chan and um got the guy's name at the
top of my head
but uh his real name as a Twitter name
and he was arrested for creating a meme
saying that Hillary Clinton wanted to
draft our daughters
and then meanwhile like you said like
you mentioned at the beginning of the
show you have you know fetterman that's
lies and lies and lies no it's probably
packs well the packs that are aligned
with Federal that are heavily funded by
the Democrat Party I did see a
commercial where he said I approved this
message right so these people Douglas
Mack these yeah Douglas Mackey he's got
a great uh legal defense fund if you
guys want to check that out uh just
Google his name uh I'm sure you guys can
find that but uh it's horrible what's
happening to but John fetterman can run
these ads that are are knowingly lies
and they put millions of dollars behind
them and John fetterman like you said
we'll probably just get a little fine or
a slap on the wrist but Douglas Mackey
has a draft Meme and now he's facing
prison time a draft all right
right you know and so it's uh it's just
BS and and it's wrong and so I think
that that whoever the next Republican
president is I hope it's I believe it's
gonna be Donald J Trump I would like to
see him pardon Douglas Mackey for this
and uh we can't say so once I agree with
Megan Kelly by the way on on her take on
the primary well that's about DeSantis
uh just her take on where the Republican
party is the Republican base and then
she was in this um interview with I
think it was Dave Rubin and he was
asking her do you think Santa's going to
get it do you think Trump's going to get
it and she said it's it's going to be
trumping right there's no question I saw
that she and I think she's right and
then Trump posted it on true social and
now it's gone like nuclear that's right
yeah basically saying she said uh
DeSantis is is made by Trump basically
everybody knows that DeSantis knows it
DeSantis needs Trump his endorsement so
there's no way he runs against them it's
true and you know it's not like I mean
does Santa's goes viral on Twitter but
at the end of the day he doesn't have
the people's support across the country
only six percent of around DeSantis as
donations come from small dollar donors
you know he's got 500 Mega donors
including you know Chicago billionaire
Ken Griffin that has given them like 140
million bucks and so like we need a
president for the people not by Wall
Street we talked about when Trump said
to lock up the journalist until they
give up their sources
and uh you you know it's it's a very bad
thing it's kind of scary but everyone
laughs and cheers about it Trump
supporters are happy I just think people
need to realize these these Democrats
most of the influential figures here's
here's let me slow down
on the left prominent political figures
are journalists on the right prominent
political figures are just us yeah like
random disparate voices some work some
are Consultants some are politicians
some work in media some are journalists
but the left lattice voices are like
activists and journalists Maggie
haverman right Rachel maddowell Taylor
so when Trump says take the person who's
writing and lock him up and then they
soon are going to find out they're going
to be someone's boyfriend they'll Spill
the Beans who in this case he by the way
would be Josh gerstein from Politico but
people cheer for this and the Democrats
are like oh it's so horrifying and I'm
like yeah you know the thing is regular
Americans despise the media so much and
this poll after poll shows it that you
are not earning any favors by in by
coming after Trump for this uh Greg
gianforte body slammed a journalist when
he was running for congress
um and they said oh he's going to lose
this is terrible this is terrible not
only did he win the Congressional race
he's now the governor of Montana
I mean so yeah yeah because
just read the room it's kind of scary I
don't like it but uh the media is such
despicable evil garbage I mean just do
this there's other ways to find that
leaker than that yeah a lot sure sure
there's better ways to find the liquor
yeah after uh Trump learn about coloring
the water I mean I'm surprised art of
four stuff but after the Federman Oz
debate Google search Dr Oz all hit
pieces every single one of them and I'm
just like this is this is insane I even
saw someone pointing out that if you go
to YouTube it's actually hard to find
the full debate that it's losing it is
unless you go to the uh YouTube channel
of the news organization that did it so
I think they they win against all the
other channels
a lot of videos what if you set it by
length and say like can't you do like 20
minutes plus or something I haven't seen
it anywhere and I've heard those videos
be deleted wow so you're talking about
the Google searches uh only being
negative odd stories but more
professional during during that uh
debate right after that debate Google
searches for how do I change my vote
we're off the charts of Pennsylvania so
the people watch that debate they're
like look they lied to me they said John
fetterman had some sort of functioning
brain it was evident that he didn't and
so now the people that you know maybe
they voted for him early they want to
vote for Doctor imagine being Connor
lamb right now another thing that you
lost at this guy uh you know which keep
in mind the Democrat and this this is
this is why keep in mind the
relationship between Democrats and media
has always been like this right they
were able to hide up the fact that FDR
couldn't walk for years they would prop
him up but the point about Fetter men
that I want to make is this he had that
stroke a week before the primary this
was not recent because they kept it a
secret and at one point he was posting
videos as if he was in these rallies and
holding events while he was in the
hospital nobody in media called him out
on this let's pull up this tweet real
quick and we'll talk about this from
MSNBC God bless they write disabled
Americans have the right to be
represented and most importantly to work
and that includes working for the US
government so we've gone from he's not
disabled to he is disabled and that
means he has a right to work for the
government in the span of what 12 hours
I mean it's a big leap right this isn't
like like okay so like Greg Abbott's in
a wheelchair that's when I hear disabled
that's kind of what I think about when
someone's got neurological damage like
fetterman when they can't actually and
by the way who was the uh who was the
MSNBC journalist who they went after her
like crazy she was 100
yeah
okay she was the only one who told the
truth I'm not an only person and and she
was attacked for it she was excoriated
for it and she was proven 100 what did
she say she said that she this guy can't
hold a conversation without the use of
these computer I wanna I wanna tell you
it is not an auditory issue they're
lying and I can give you one I can cite
an easy example from the debate that
proves it is actually cognitive
impairment when he said hi good night
everyone yeah now hold on yeah he didn't
accidentally say goodbye what happened
was his brain understands that evening
and night are are synonymous
but it didn't understand that good night
and good evening are opposites right
that is cognitive impairment like his
brain was able to recall the word and
then said the wrong one in that context
that is cognitive impairment
so when you know and and we've been
discussing this so have you heard what
what Bannon did over on war room to
cover this no so this is hilarious um
but it's it's very insightful as well so
he's been really really focused on
transhumanism and this whole idea of man
machine merger and so he's taken his
transhumanist editor Joe Allen and he
sent him up to Pennsylvania to cover
fetterman as the world's first cyborg
candidate
because when you look at it this this is
like a prototype that they're trying to
roll out now obviously the tech isn't
quite there yet but they're trying to
see that they can get away with actually
hooking someone's mind up to a computer
and then running them as a candidate and
my question is now we saw this with
closed captioning are they going to come
out next and say well you know it's
really not fair to only give him the
closed captioning we should be able to
give him multiple choice answers that
the computer feeds him you know based on
uh position statements and policy papers
or he can choose from or wait to the
point where they they wheel in on a
hospital bed a totally paralyzed person
who's just not moving and then it rolls
up and there's like a an electrode going
into the brainstem hello I am John
Federman I am running for Senate vote
for me why not just make it really
obvious and get a mannequin and a puppet
I think that would be more I said that
was much better than your Elon Musk oh
yeah the computer that was actually
pretty good robot voice you know most
kind of hard to in person it's very hard
to pursue yeah they're all puppets well
I mean in this case in this case this is
why the regime wants people like
fetterman like Joe Biden because they
don't want someone up there who's
actually asking questions they don't
want someone up there who's got you know
like like look at Blake Masters right
you put Blake Masters in a room that
guy's gonna be asking questions he's
going to say how does this work where
does the money come from all this
fetterman's gonna say
green yes yes Schumer what do you want
yes and that's it that's all he's going
to do my favorite part of the fetterman
debate was when he said quote I want to
look every woman in Pennsylvania stray
in the face
and that was the sentence could you
imagine how terrifying that would be for
the women of Pennsylvania yeah my mom's
not down for that I would definitely you
know I'm running the eyes campaign I'm
running that quote just over fetterman's
face over like over and over again
randomly yelled out Doug mastriano
but yeah he did but my favorite question
tonight was when asked about whether he
supported fracking or not he said yeah I
support fracking and I don't I don't and
I support fracking and I support Frankie
so here's my analysis this is my
analysis
he said I support fracking okay that's
it that's positive and I don't I don't
that's two negatives but then he said
and I support fracking and I support
fracking so when you add those together
you get one statement of I support
fracking so he does support fragrance so
because the question is she doesn't
support fracking for the fact Checkers
he doesn't support fracking that was the
question was that they they pointed out
they were like John we have you on
record a couple years ago saying that
you don't support fracking we have this
this uh you know was it a letter that he
signed open letter that he signed
pledging to ban fracking from a couple
years ago he's going to and they said
well John can you explain this and my
take on it was so like oh you're
consultant right let's say you're
working for fetterman you know that
question's coming up at the debate you
know that fracking is so important
mastriano was was In This Very Room
talking about how we got to build
pipelines to Erie pipelines to
Philadelphia fracking all over the place
Marcella Shale Etc so you know this is
coming up in the people of Pennsylvania
won it you would have had a prepared and
some kind of way to deal with this and
it seemed to me like it was sort of like
his he went okay mind search for answer
and he just it just came up this glaring
404 error 404 error but he knew that the
answer was that he had to say that he
supported it so he just straight up went
with it well if I was federman's
consultant there's no way in hell I
would have let that guy on stage like
well I'm not saying you yeah yeah
that just sucked the race and there was
polling that came out uh today uh on
October 25 Poll and it had eyes up three
and that was before the debate and so
it's not gonna it's not gonna end well
here for
um the first cyborg candidate uh I think
it was a failed experiment first world's
first they should they should shut this
this program down
which party will win the U.S Senate
election in Pennsylvania in 2022 take a
look at that
I mean there you go
The Biggest Loser of this all is Conor
lamb and I think that's seriously we
don't talk about that enough look at
that right there that's the debate you
know when Connor lamp first won you know
was that 2016 or 2014 Jack that was 18.
well he he was basically like this is
the next Boy Wonder this is our next
Obama and he loses to John fetterman
well because he was one of those he was
like the blue dog Democrat yeah right he
was one of those because he was a uh he
was a marine right uh he's always a
marine he was in Western Pennsylvania he
beats Keith rothfuss so a guy who was in
like a trumpy area of Pennsylvania but
is able to pick up those sort of they
call him the Reagan democrats he might
just start calling the Trump Democrats
now but he's able to win them over by
saying hey I'm a Democrat but I'm not as
I'm not part of the slime in the sludge
right but the problem is their primary
base for the entire state of
Pennsylvania wants that uh and doesn't
like somebody who served in the military
I mean like like a colonizer murder and
a baby killer and all these things and
so they reject him he's sitting there
cooling his heels now having to watch
this entire debacle day in day out they
like him they like John fetterman the
man who chased down that unarmed black
man with a shotgun when he was the mayor
of that that small town that was insane
he defended it yeah he defended it
yeah
safe or something like that I was just
keeping everyone in my town they
understood what that was about and I
like yeah I mean I think we all
understand what that was about John wow
they want to switch them out they want
to switch them out this is what they
want to do they want to set it up and
the state of Pennsylvania we've already
got some issues on this and and Luke you
mentioned a little bit um before the
show but they've already said they're
talking the Secretary of State acting
Secretary of State Lee Chapman is now
saying well we may have a bit of a delay
after election night and the state
Republicans now have already put forward
a letter saying why did you send out a
quarter of a million mail-in ballots
without verifying the identity of the
people you were sending them to First
the way you're supposed to Under
Pennsylvania State Law that's a huge red
flag and now you're in a situation where
if if Shapiro wins and fetterman wins
fetterman I I guarantee you will not
serve a day in the Senate and Shapiro
will pick someone or actually Tom Wolf
will probably just pick someone in the
lame duck session and my money would be
on the wife on Giselle Republicans need
to sue in Pennsylvania right now to
demand an election day limit
that's it you do not count ballots after
election day the Constitution prescribes
a single day for the election soon now
and then you know because I think the
Supreme Court's still Democrat leaning
if if in Pennsylvania in Pennsylvania
yeah if it gets rejected you can cite
that and appeal and be like hey we
started this fight before the election
keeping with that the United States
Supreme Court has a ruling out on
Pennsylvania when it comes to this
because Pennsylvania was saying hey
we'll accept your ballots even if
they're undated even if they're undated
whereas everyone knows no that's that's
not how that works it has to be signed
has to be dated correct mailing address
verified identity all of it that's
Pennsylvania State Law Pennsylvania
secretary of state says now go ahead and
send those in on Data in the
Pennsylvania Attorney General who is
Josh Shapiro is running for governor
could not care less and so they've come
out at the state of Pennsylvania level
saying we don't care what the United
States Supreme Court says we'll accept
the ballots either way and here's the
problem once you separate that ballot
from the secrecy envelope once you
separate it from the outer envelope and
put that ballot in there's no
identifying information on it it's going
to go right in with all the other
ballots you know I just realized about
fetterman's cognitive impairment is that
it really it works out really really
well if you think about it most people
didn't watch that debate now what can
you do
if fetterman is asked a question right
so actually Jack let's let's play ask me
if I support fracking uh uh Tim do you
do you support fracking I absolutely
support fracking but I don't support
fracking next question
and now here's what you do maybe you
just no I I that but you heard my answer
because now my campaign can take both
Clips right right and send the I support
to the areas where it's big and I
opposed to the urban centers and you get
them all but you were so articulate like
fetterman can't say it like that no I
know I'm saying think about what he's
discovered on accident right so now
you're gonna have future candidates
being like I believe we should be
raising taxes on the wealthy wow I also
believe we should be cutting taxes on
our on our principal job creators no no
Mr fetterman what's your what's your
stance on abortion Mr fetterman I am
absolutely pro-choice and I believe
abortion is wrong and I am pro-life now
what about these what about these these
child uh gender transitions I 100
support gender affirming care for
children and I believe the state should
not allow doctors to perform child sex
change the final question Second
Amendment second amendments Mr
lieutenant governor I support the Second
Amendment rights of all of the people in
this state in this country
and I think we need Swift gun control
and gun reform to prevent violent
offenders and people who shouldn't have
guns from having them which means a ban
on large capacity magazines and assault
weapons and then you just clip whatever
you need social media audience
you can feel free to use that one for in
the future politicians you know I I may
have been I I may be hitting gold here
right I kind of feel like they're
already better fetterman gets the credit
federal well I mean with with Hillary
Clinton putting the fake accent and AOC
doing it yeah that's what politicians do
anyway they tell you what they people
want to hear they lie they they make
promises they can't keep they say yeah I
support this if enough people want it
and then when they get into office they
go to all the lobbyists they go to all
the multinational corporations and
bankers and they're like just tell me
what to do they're like okay and they
carry out those orders screwing you over
yeah that's Second Amendment impression
you just did sounded like just like John
cornyn senator from Texas is that what
he did oh my God the great state of
Texas they love their guns they are so
proud of their great too up until this
last convention and then you have a guy
named John cornyn who gets elected says
I you know defend your 2A and then you
have the Republican senator from Texas
that's tapped by Mitch McConnell to
negotiate with the Democrats a bill to
take away the Second Amendment rights of
the American citizens all right he got
booed off the stage now
if I was running and I was on a debate
stage ask me if I support the Second
Amendment
oh wait are you Tim are you fetterman
not me I'm me Tim do you support the
Second Amendment I do and if elected I
will work to repeal all gun control laws
as all of them are unconstitutional that
includes the NFA and I want to make sure
everyone here is fully aware that I
believe the second amendment protects
your right to keep nuclear weapons and
biological weapons as well next question
the Wuhan Doctrine I'm I'm dead serious
you want to amend the Constitution by
all means amend the Constitution is a
process for it but the right to keeping
their arms included cannons and warships
right and still does this is when I said
this and like all the lefties got really
mad they were like two more people
tenants are not illegal they're not
illegal but not only that it is private
companies that have all of these these
weapons anyway it is it is private firms
that are funding bio weapons it is
private companies that are making nukes
and other bombs it's not like it's just
the government that has nukes these
people don't understand what's going on
yeah the US government went to Echo
Health Alliance and they're like please
give us your notes about what you were
doing touring at the Wuhan Institute
right before the coronavirus outbreak
and Echo Health Alliance said screw you
we're a private entity we could do what
we want we're not giving you those notes
and they didn't boom so so who do you
think makes the nuclear weapons it's
like do people think the government
right now has like an arms division of
scientists that are manufactured like in
a manufacturing base that's making
nuclear weapons or the bio weapons or
the artificial intelligence or the
latest next technology that we don't
even know about that could wipe out
Humanity but but in in a pragmatic sense
when you're looking at some of these
companies If This Were Russia or China
we would automatically Define these
companies as extensions of the
government right and so when it comes to
the United States we play this this game
that oh these are private entities even
if look at a company like Boeing right
this is a company where by and large
it's obviously an extension of the US
government when you look at some of the
way that even big Tech the way that a
lot of big Tech works because they've
been given so many deals because because
they clearly work with government at a
very high level which we've seen in
lawsuit after lawsuit that it's it's
kind of silly for us to say oh these are
completely separate from government when
they obviously have so much connective
tissue let's pull this next story this
was crazy this morning so uh New York
Post employee responsible for violent
reprehensible content on the website and
Twitter accounts this looked like a hack
at first no one say based no one say
based in a chat well in reference to the
school one specifically the rest of them
were kind of freaky but there was one
post where they said to arrest the
teachers unions or something but here's
the story
uh this morning you know I'm preparing
my segment I usually record around nine
or so and then all of a sudden I see the
New York post Tweet out a call to to end
the life of a particular apology I'm
trying to be very careful because it's
crazy stuff and that apparently Ben
Shapiro wrote it and uh it was taken
down within a few minutes it was
archived a bunch of other posts popped
up where there were calls for death on
many other politicians and then one of
them that you're referring to Jack said
to arrest teachers unions and you're
like okay well you know Case by case I
think there was but it turns out to have
been a rogue employees I think there was
not actually Christopher I think there
were some real stories mixed in with
some of the fake ones because I'm
reading this one this one this one seems
well this headline seems real man shoved
eight inch deodorant can up his butt
left it in there for three weeks since a
picture of Adam kinzinger no no no no no
the trick here is the headline was real
but that wasn't actually Adam kinzinger
uh the photo you got you got you you
could see his photos
right so a lot of memes started getting
made that
like I felt I thought that was actually
legit of Adam kinzinger but I guess I'm
wrong I I someone put his picture there
they put his picture there right but the
problem is now is that when you look at
some of the crazy news that's come out
just in the last 48 hours you're like
wait is this another hack or is this a
real one now yeah the Adam Kinsey one
had me believed yeah but that one was
from a long time ago I think it was it
was like September or something the real
story but this is uh a rogue employee
did this and the question is why
why somebody were they Democrat I mean
to me honestly and I don't have any
inside info on this um but and I do know
people at the post but um uh I I think
this is probably just like a work
related thing
um seems to me like somebody was just
disgruntled at work had access but it
was overwhelmingly right wing targeting
the left
but and did you see hokel's campaign is
using it as legitimate yeah so let me
just stress this okay you're saying he's
a left-wing guy who did it I think or
it's politically motivated uh Kathy
hokel right am I getting her name wrong
yeah somebody had to know that it would
be their campaign pointed out that what
the New York Post said the vile violent
misogyny was wrong and they must answer
for it and it was like yo guy they said
they were hacked like nobody believed it
was real but here I said this this
morning when it happened there's going
to be evil Democrats who know it's BS
but know they can use it to lie to their
constituents and they're doing it 100
well that goes do what you're saying
earlier right that if someone only sees
this headline came up from the New York
Post and then here's governor hokel
who's someone that I trust and believe
because I'm a liberal Democrat and she's
saying that it was real and now I hear
some crazy Republican like Alex
bruzowitz or Jack pesobic well I'm not
going to believe did this dude get paid
the biggest I'll tell you right now wow
yeah right now they can run an attack ad
saying in a shocking New York Post
headline Ben Shapiro called for right
and then because it's a fact it is a
fact according to the New York Post the
New York Post published this and so the
only thing Ben can do is Sue the New
York Post for damages because they're
the ones who said it that means every
single political action committee can
now use all of those headlines and say
in a shocking New York Post article
Republicans called for violence against
Joe Biden they'll say it and you can't
sue him now
congratulations
we'll see if it goes that far I mean if
it does I think it'll be called out
automatically I would call it out
is actually claiming it was it was real
and they're saying that your house do we
have our statements yeah the statement
came out really here we go look Jen
Goodman says the New York Post has long
fostered an ugly toxic conversation on
their front pages and social accounts
but these posts are more disgusting and
vile than usual the New York Post needs
to immediately explain how this
reprehensible content was made public
while the post has made its preferences
very clear in the New York governor's
race there is no room for this violent
sexist rhetoric in our politics we
demand answers this was pre-planned yeah
I'm sorry
that seems like that was look they know
that like you know we've talked about
Shapiro in Pennsylvania but you look at
New York Lee zeldin has been up in like
three of the last four polls that I've
seen in New York State uh hokel who was
a a candidate that an incumbent that
nobody actually voted for looks like
she's going to lose to zeldon and I
think she should by the way Zelda would
be a fantastic governor for New York um
I pray for the people of New York that
that they'll be able to be represented
by him in Albany but the idea that they
would have this statement already
pre-planned and the New York Post said
they were hacked 45 minutes before they
put it up
I mean this is crazy they knew what they
were doing because look at look at what
the implication is there the implication
is that these are the things that the
New York Post wishes it could write you
know because there's always that that
hit on on people that are conservatives
people on the right Etc well they'll say
well we know what you really mean we
know what that's a dog whistle yeah so
this is like America first as a dog yes
dog whistle right fascism globalist is a
slur right Global anti-semitic now they
say yeah so I just say internationalism
so is so is Alzheimer's Adolf I got
called anti-semitic for that one
recently but uh but I had some rabbis on
Twitter that came to my defense and they
said Alex is a great friend of the
Jewish people so I use Alzheimer's Adolf
still I just say internationalist
Nationalist and internationalist there
you go and then so I just say globalist
immediately because look at what they're
saying toxic conversation on their front
pages and social accounts more
disgusting and vile than usual but the
implication they're being that all of
the content of the New York Post is
disgusting and vile and again
what did we have exactly two years ago
was an article written by the New York
Post
that was censored resoundingly Alex you
just spoke about this
and it was Hunter Biden's laptop and
that was broken by the exact same
newspaper as the one that was targeted
today yeah yeah that's a good point and
they were censored on big Tech social
media before sharing their stuff
everywhere that that according to many
polls would have changed the election
yeah but that story was was shunned the
federal intelligence agencies intervened
and told big Tech social media companies
this story could be connected to Russian
disinformation campaigns and if you know
what's good for you you're not gonna
post this story remember Mark Zuckerberg
said they visited him they visited Mark
Zuckerberg and told him yeah that there
was going to be Russian discount
information which specific specifically
to this story when the FBI knew for a
fact after interviewing Tony babalinski
that it wasn't of Russian disinformation
story they knew it was true they were
not verified it with Tony and they
already had the laptop yeah they
interviewed Hunter Biden's business
partner who came there and verified that
the laptop was real and they still went
around the big Tech social media company
saying don't run this just crazy they
went and arrested what was it 12
pro-lifers yeah because you're not
legally allowed to protest at abortion
clinics but when the protesters showed
up at the Supreme Court Justices Holmes
which is also illegal they did nothing
uh not just protesters showing up but
illegal at our uh Supreme Court Justice
homes Tim they had an actual antifa
psychopath who showed up outside of it
was Kavanaugh's house right yeah they
did a restaurant with a gun they
arrested him after he turned himself in
by calling his sister and then calling
9-1-1 he was there with zip ties with a
backpack with duct tape
I believe he wanted to capture
potentially torture Kavanaugh and his
family his daughters and he said
specifically that this was because of
the Dobbs decision and because of his
second amendment positions he flew all
the way from California to do this which
very interested to how he purchased the
weapons Etc but when Alito came out
recently and said the Dobbs leak led to
assassination threats MSNBC and their
viewers were attacking him for saying
that because and this goes to your point
earlier they don't even know that this
happened they don't even know I disagree
there was assassination I think they are
evil people and they don't care I'm
talking about the followers yeah yeah uh
so again uh you know there's this this
tweet Aiden Paladin put out on Twitter
where she's like here's citation all
these studies showing that the leftism
is is dominated by Envy hatred violence
you know greed and I'm like just like
every Communists the history of
Communism yeah yeah it sounds about
right you know the problem is that
people keep thinking uh that they are
that that there is a left and that they
want to be on the left but they're
looking at a cult of violent extremists
thinking that represents true like
leftist values yeah and there's also a
lot of mental disorders and
radicalization that happens because of
big Tech social media censorship and the
echo Chambers it creates with its
algorithm and the man that you were just
describing I just looked up the story uh
he said that he was there to kill the
Supreme Court Justice to specifically
take him out yeah and to to ruin him
because of the disinformation because of
the propaganda because of the
psychological warfare that's happening
right now in our political system that
is literally pushing people to try to
assassinate other individuals because of
wrong think that's crazy exactly also
almost 200 days later we still don't
know who leaked from scotus yep and
there's no one like is there even an
ongoing investigation it's almost like
they can't find the leaker and they
can't find the j6 uh you know uh pipe
bomber that guy still but they can track
down the 12 uh you know peaceful
pro-life protesters they can track down
thousands of Mega grandmas who showed up
at the Capitol on January if that was a
conservative we would have known in two
seconds it would be Behind Bars by now
absolutely I have good news though I got
good news guys let's pull this story
from the daily wire
Schumer warns Biden on hot Mike that
Democrats are vulnerable in Key State
quote we're in danger that's a crazy
thing for someone to say like privately
we're in danger you're in danger why
because when the Republicans win there's
going to be inquiries maybe I really
don't think they'll do much but this is
the story they're basically talking
about Pennsylvania the seat that seat
we're in danger in that seat Schumer
told Biden adding a few months later
it's close we'll see so I they're
thinking that it's going to show are you
seeing the breaking news on Elon and
Twitter yeah it's official it's not only
is it official but it says uh Elon just
17 minutes ago Elon has closed the deal
and fired the CEO and CFO
you know what we say to that hey
hey
goodbye and they fired vagina yes right
gone who was response personally
responsible for suspense spending we got
it we got it we got it right here check
it out from the Washington uh this is uh
uh Jorge vanilla posting he did it Elon
Musk fired the CEO CFO and censor in
Chief they say CEO parag Agarwal Chief
Financial Officer Ned Segal and Vijaya
got a head of legal policy trust and
safety were all fired according to the
people Elon Elon was listening when when
a prince must commit atrocities commit
them early
is breaking wow that's why she there we
go yeah she knew Elon okay I'm sorry
look she should have listened to Tim
Poole when she had a pool tried to set
it right she bought herself three years
well actually uh vagina if you're if you
are listening uh it was I think it was
what early 2019 yeah I I said you guys
can't keep doing this and I actually
said to Jack if you keep doing this
there's going to be contactors to Dorsey
what did I say well Jesus
I said there's going to be violence and
then I joked I was like I'm building a
van I'm gonna go live down and and then
they all laughed and then what did Joe
say you know a few a couple months ago
he was like he's like you know I had Tim
pool on my show and he was talking about
Civil War and I'm like nah get out of
here man you're crazy now I think he
might be right so you know these people
should have listened to what I was
saying when I was saying it they didn't
understand though I think which I
understood the last thing she says is
thank you for the feedback well now IT
issues to my attention took three years
but she got fired so uh I would I would
I really would love to have yeah my
phone's lighting up Prague has left the
building wow I wanna I wanna sit down
with Joe anymore and talk about all this
stuff and uh because Vijaya is trending
Vijaya is trending well look we did we
did that episode and a lot of people
promote the story like I only had a
couple hundred thousand subscribers I
didn't have a big YouTube channel or
something like that and uh Joe knew who
I was we talked for a bit he ended up
seeing a video where I did a commentary
on Twitter censorship I commented on his
episode with Jack Dorsey that got that
got panned explaining some of the issues
that I thought were wrong Joe hits me up
I go out to his show after the show he
says how would you like to come on with
with Jack and their head of legal and I
was like are you nuts dude I can't do
that and he's like now come let's do it
we did it and uh I wouldn't call it
perfect there's probably a lot of things
I'd look back on and say I probably
could have brought up other issues but I
think it was extremely important they
did not expect it the things that that I
brought up notably that they're
misgendering policy of misgendering
policy overtly favors a leftist
worldview they didn't expect that they
thought we have rules they broke the
rules they get banned I came in and said
that rule set only applies to people who
believe it and the conservatives have an
inverted worldview on what misgendering
is and they were like oh
well here you go that's it so wow glad
to see it uh I really would love to talk
to Elon but come on you know we've like
I've tweeted at him several times it is
what it is you get them on the show you
get them on the show if he's the richest
guy in the world so good luck with that
I suppose or just privately trying to
reach out being like hey maybe we could
try to help you somehow well I think one
of the issues with Elon is that the
statement he I think the statement he
issued to advertisers makes sense from a
business perspective he doesn't want
them to flee thinking he's going to make
a hate speech platform he's got to
control some of the narrative I think he
gets that but he also specifically said
in that in that letter hey you know you
get to choose your experience here by
expressing your preferences you want to
see something you could see something
you don't want to see something you
don't have to see it this is a rational
adult take to take on the situation that
leaves you responsible for what you
decide you want to see on big Tech
social media instead of an all-knowing
algorithm that of course will curate
content for you and act as a form of
mass hypnosis mind control so this this
is this is a step in the right direction
they also fired uh he also fired Twitter
as general counsel Sean edgett oh thank
goodness one of the executives was
escorted out of the building
if this is all we get thank you Elon
Musk lock him up if if tomorrow Elon
just goes uh I'm going to keep Twitter
the exact same way it's always been I'll
be like hey it was worth it for that one
day where we all got to laugh about the
firing and escorting out of these people
what happens if someone refuses to leave
right that's what happens I'm not
leaving
here's the cartoon you got to make
you've already got the animations from
when you did the the video with Vijaya
she's holding on to the wall going now
and they're pulling her out of the
building well the next thing she needs
to be dragged before Congress and face
the wrath of Marjorie Taylor green and
we need answers about why they suspended
our great president Donald J Trump I
found the actual quote from Machiavelli
I've been messing it up but you know
paraphrasing it the actual quote is this
cruelties are well used if it is
permitted to speak well of evil that are
carried out in a single stroke done out
of necessity to protect oneself and then
are not continued but are instead
converted into the greatest possible
benefit for the subjects
the greatest convert so that's my
message to Elon convert this convert
this moment
into the greatest possible benefit for
the subject so who should we have uh I
you know in terms of replacing Vijaya
I'd say I don't know
um Donald Trump James Lindsay
you know James Lindsay are you working
right now like what are you working on
he should only appoint people that are
currently banned on Twitter my Twitter
trust and safety team my no Milo's
Milo's busy with interning for Marjorie
Taylor green who is the um uh important
work Ron Paul friggin Ron Ron Paul
Martin was it Martha um
the the liberal who is the who was um
Julian Assange Edward Snowden make it
make them official advisors make them
officially join us company Julian
Assange get him in there snow didn't get
him in there what was what was her exact
role the head of trust and safety do I
just get rid of that department
because I don't think her apartment
actually cared about trust safety sure
sure but look some there there are
people who post criminal and you know
images right of child abuse is the
easiest example you do need someone to
be like hey we are actively making sure
this stuff is not it's not easy I mean
of all nights to not have Ian on we kind
of could use his perspective because he
did this stuff with Minds you know he
compounded it he did a lot of the stuff
Megan Murphy excuse me Megan Murphy
right right right yeah so uh anyway
you know uh there's a lot of hard work
that goes into action look wait wait
censorship is good I I censor hold on
Snapchat censorship is good censorship
is is a neutral term what we're saying
what what we don't like is political and
biased censorship what we do like is
when they censor images of child abuse
absolutely and then forward that to the
police and have those people arrested or
if you're like hey I know how to break
into the bank here's the code here's the
exactly security route Etc that is
censorship and so for someone to be
sitting back there being like here's Tim
Poole's social security number exactly
get it out of there doxing I'm not I
disagree with even though doxing's First
Amendment you're allowed to do it sure I
think we all agree they did it delivers
a tick tock right so address name
whatever like revenge porn right I'm
against Revenge one so you need someone
sitting there reviewing content to pull
that stuff the problem is they decided
certain political Concepts were also
objectionable and that's where we said
hey hey hey hey hey that's bad that's
journalism not just political Concepts
but actual journalism and whether you
were on the left wing or right wing a
lot of people got hit because they dared
to question The Establishment the agenda
and the official narratives that are
being shoved down our throats and a lot
of people a lot of people just think
it's it's right-wing institutions no a
lot of left-wing institutions uh
anti-war.com free thought project uh
antimedia.com so many other individuals
got hit and they were and a lot of
people have forgotten about them but
these individuals also deserve to have
their accounts back deserve uh Carey
weather also another individual banned
on Twitter for some reason she's also
another fellow Anarchist again that was
just hit and dinged for what expressing
critical thinking of what they were
trying to get us all to conform to look
that that's why I'm calling for a
general amnesty yeah bring back the
crass and steam Brothers
called for Trump to be reinstated
breaking news he says somebody
Luke mentioned this the other day but
these journalists right now are going
yes yes yes yes
right now there's like alarms going off
at newsrooms and they're like the
Coliseum is reopening Trump may be
coming back yeah we got to get a team
together for this I'm gonna call the
advertisers let them know our views are
going through the roof let's get it
you've seen that that video they made of
like of like Elon in the uh in the
control room and then
Twitter so this could potentially happen
tomorrow right well the second Trump
comes back onto Twitter there's a
certain Republican politician who thinks
he's a contender for 2024 who's going to
lose like all of the the Limelight and
Mike Pence a lot of these Republicans
have benefited like that think that they
have a chance at 24s but have benefited
from Trump not being on the Town Square
so and he's about to re-enter the arena
is he because he says he's not going to
do it well Donald Trump said
specifically I don't care
um
but he publicly said I don't care I
don't want to be on Elon musk's platform
I want to be on Truth social that's what
he said let's just say that it has to be
on Twitter let's just say I know he does
but he says he's not going to and he has
a big ego and his ego usually decides a
lot of the policies there might have
been a reason he had to say that but
he's going to be back if he's coming
back okay okay so right now uh a fatter
version of me is is being tweeted about
by Benny Johnson is a clip so I I want
to play it because I don't even know
what I'm saying in this with a list of
private phone numbers addresses yet
Kathy Griffin
she's fine the guy who threatened the
lives of these kids in Covington and
said lock them in the school and burn it
down you did nothing I mean he got
suspended I take his tweets down was he
banned for threatening the lives of kids
absolutely not so again we have and I'm
I'm happy to talk about all these
details we have our policies that are
meant to protect people and they're
meant to enable free expression as long
as you're not trying to silence somebody
else now we take a variety of different
enforcement mechanisms around that
sometimes you get warned sometimes your
Tweet is forced to be deleted it's a
very rare occasion where we will
outright suspend someone without any
sort of warning
that's them laughing to understand
what's happening what did you guys do
with it but Tim those accounts were
actioned they may not have been action
the way you wanted to to but the the
tweets were forced to be deleted and the
account for sure I I can penalty for
that so I understand that what kind of a
penalty well again as I said earlier Joe
we don't uh usually automatically
suspend accounts with one violation
because we want people we want people to
understand what they did wrong and give
them an opportunity not to do it again
right and it's it's a big thing to kick
someone off the platform and I take that
very very seriously so so I want to make
sure that when someone violates our
rules they understand what happened and
they're given an opportunity to you know
get back on the platform and change
their behavior and so in many of these
cases what happens is we will force
someone to acknowledge that their tweet
violated our rules forced them to delete
that tweet before they can get back on
the platform and in in many cases if
they do it again we give them a timeout
which is like seven days and we say look
you've done it again it's a temporary
suspension if you do it time out you're
a mom I forgot about that totally a mom
exactly and a new mom too and if you do
it again then you're done right so it's
kind of like you know three strikes so
it's sort of like baseball and so in
some of these cases that Tim is
referencing I have to imagine because
these tweets were deleted they are
violations of our rules people are upset
that the account came back again and was
allowed to say other things but we did
take action on those tweets they were
violations so there was uh there was a
period on Twitter
where people were saying the word
groomer and
um it means a specific thing it's a
reference to an adult of any background
of any sexuality or origin or race
trying to introduce sexualized Concepts
to children for the sake of you know
getting them into sexual circumstances
and that word still means that there was
a campaign by a bunch of leftists that
it was actually an anti-lgbtq slur
Twitter
initiated a new rule without making any
announcements retroactively enforcing
this as hate speech and then I got
locked out of my account it said simply
delete the tweet and you can come back
well I got news for you Twitter I just
did not I don't care about the platform
there's a lot of people who are like the
you know I refuse to get down I'm like
delete whatever dude like it's like
who's gonna see me having said something
three months ago that they're banning
now the tweet's gone and I routinely
erase old tweets anyway but the point is
she's lying I broke no rules I expressed
a legitimate political opinion Vijaya
you never fix the platform Jack Dorsey
and Vijaya told me after that show we
are working on a path to Redemption it
should not be a life sentence when
someone says something wrong for the
third time they never did it Jack never
did it she never did it good effing
riddance they were lying through their
teeth they never followed through with
anything that they promised and they
still began to use the platform as their
own kind of political punishment tool
for trying to hurt people for expressing
the wrong thing again Jordan Peterson
he's still locked out of Twitter to this
day right now which is absolutely crazy
I don't think he did anything wrong I I
think a lot of people didn't do anything
wrong and they were taken out of the
major town hall that everyone depends on
for speech look she got what she
deserved yeah she just got it but but
here's my I I have a question actually
because should we put these two stories
together should we connect some Dots
here because yeah so we were told right
that the Tesla Engineers were going in
to look at the code that was what this
afternoon and then here we are and it's
it's three hours behind so it's about 6
p.m San Francisco time and now just a
few hours after the Tesla Engineers were
allowed to look at Twitter's code the
entire as we would say in the Navy Head
Shed the entire leadership it looks like
the almost the entire c-suite the head
of the snake the head of the snake has
been complete completely lopped off by
Elon Musk on day one day one you're
fired that's correct but also I think he
found something that's my point I think
he found it absolutely how could he not
because obviously they were doing
something wrong obviously they were
fudging the data they were lifting the
scales they were doing something that
was absolutely wrong and unfair because
he's got like he's got liability now
that if he found something and he didn't
get rid of the employees as fast as
possible then the liability would be on
him so here's here's uh there's going to
be a Texas a tax exchange that ended up
getting released between former CEO
parag and I love this he says you are
free to tweet is Twitter dying or
anything else about Twitter but it's my
responsibility to tell you that it's not
helping me make Twitter better in the
current context next time we speak I'd
like you to I'd like to I'd like to you
provide you perspective on the level of
internal distraction right now and how
it's hurting our ability to do work I
hope the AMA will help people get to
know you to understand why you believe
in Twitter and to trust you and I'd like
the company to get to a place where we
are more resilient and don't get
distracted but we aren't there right now
Elon responded what did you get done
this week I'm not joining the board this
is a waste of time we'll make an offer
to take Twitter private imagine being in
this position and someone's Rich enough
to buy out your company and you're like
you listen here young man I'm gonna tell
you what for what you can't do and it's
like bro I will buy your company and
fire yourself a letter right what letter
that the open letter that was being
circulated by Twitter oh yeah they were
like don't fire any of us we demand it
for our political beliefs they said
right you shouldn't they said you
shouldn't come down on someone for their
political belief that's incredible this
is a group of people that I think for
people like Vijaya go back to listen to
the
the hubris that's in her voice three
years ago talking to you Tim and the
response that I'm I'm your mother I tell
you when you're in time out when you're
not I tell you when you've been a good
boy or when you've been a bad boy I will
correct your behavior based on my
beliefs this is someone who never in her
entire life and it's not just her but
it's it's all these employees who sign
this letter they've never had to face
actual accountability at any point in
their entire lives until about five
minutes true and that woman that you
just talked about you know just had that
mindset she also had that mindset when
thinking about the president of the
United States When Donald Trump was
banned he was sitting in the Oval Office
and as Luke mentioned it is the most
important influential platform in the
world and that girl boss Vijaya which is
a fun name to say by the way I'm just
gonna throw that out there but she
banned the sitting president of the
United States for a lie which has been
proven to be a lie there needs to be
accountability the first thing
I would love to see or I should say I
hope Elon I just I know it won't happen
but Elon if you're listening invite Alex
Jones to a tour of Twitter HQ right now
just bring him in yeah drum around and
that's it that's it let me just give a
tour and say you know here's what's
going on here's what's happening and uh
the reason I I and I mean this quite
seriously and the reason is many of
these people in San Francisco think fake
things about Alex Jones because the
media's lied to them they have never
escaped they've never been outside of
this bubble bring Alex Jones into the
bubble let him walk around introducing
the people hey nice to meet you and
he'll and that's all they'll get and
they'll be like that actually wasn't so
bad start normalizing interactions so be
it Trump trump Jr Alex Jones Milo
whoever invite them in you know say come
in be polite I want to show you around
and you can introduce to these people
and we're going to try and solve these
problems the political bias that is a
huge step towards having people be like
well Alex came here yesterday and
nothing happened he just kind of walked
around and smiled and shook hands I was
scared I thought it was going to be bad
and then why would you think that all of
this goes back to the anti-bullying
campaigns all of this that this idea
that you can't stand up for yourself
that you must avoid confrontation and
then take everything to a higher
authority that you have to go to if
someone's bullying you it's don't don't
stand up for yourself don't assert
yourself have no self-confidence just
run to the teacher run to the principal
be a snitch snitch be a tattletail all
this stuff you have created this culture
that has infected the entire rest of our
society where we cannot you and you see
this by the way with you see it with
Millennials you certainly see it with
Zoomers they cannot handle direct
confrontation even if it's someone that
in their mind right is is a bad person
like and you see it when these videos
with Alex Jones is kind of like walking
around Seattle or whatever it is and
they see him and their their faces just
you know begin contorting uh it's it's
they you've actually created this this
mental weakness and crutch in people
that never used to exist before this is
a great idea Tim
um and it's and it shouldn't just be
Alex Jones it should be everyone that
was banned for political speech yeah no
let's have a day where all the Twitter
employees now have to meet the people
that they banned on social media I have
an outing have a picnic day bring out
every single person that was punished
for their political beliefs and and have
a day where they all just meet each
other and and and then that would be
beautiful to see first of all and and
second of all you could get rid of a lot
of the stigma a lot of the tensions
between everyone and all the fear as you
mentioned and uh I think that would be
magical to see yeah I I like that idea
and Jack you're 100 spelled I want the
anti you know bullying campaigns like it
sounds nice in theory but the lasting
consequences are are horrible yeah I'm
not going to tell the whole story since
we're on YouTube but let's just say that
my my four-year-old was at preschool and
I came home and his his clothes were a
little a little dirty and I said I said
Jack Jack what happened he said oh one
of the one of the kids pushed me at
school today and I said okay
I'm not going to finish the entire story
but let's just say I didn't tell him to
go and run to the teacher the next time
it happens yeah absolutely I mean that's
what my father did when I got bullied I
got pushed down he said you see that kid
you get the biggest one you punch him as
hard as you can in the face and I did
and I stood up for myself is this
statement from Trump real
congratulations to Elon Musk on his
purchase of Twitter many people are
saying that change was needed as the old
management was too concerned with the
woke agenda I have been told that my
account will be back up and running on
Monday we will see happy to be able to
engage with an african-american-owned
business
I don't know that doesn't sound like him
but but it's important to note here that
in May of this year Elon Musk
specifically said that when he would buy
Twitter he would allow the former
president of the United States Donald
Trump to return with his account Donald
Trump then swiftly answered when Elon
Musk said he would bring him back saying
quote specifically I am not going on
Twitter I'm going to stay on truth I
hope Elon buys Twitter because he'll
make improvements to it and he is a good
good man but I am going to be staying on
truth I will be truthing that's the
official yeah
I don't think the statement the
statement that I just said right now
the one I mentioned a funny meme but
look you keep saying that yes we get it
but Trump has to be on Twitter period he
can say whatever he wants it's
irrelevant he has to be on Twitter
period right of course if you want to be
a part of the conversation yes will he
that's the big question yes he will I'm
a betting man I I bet yes
um I will make a gentleman's bet with
you good sir he will come back on the
platform this the 60 to 80 mil how many
followers did he have 80 188 88 million
it was on the last one I saw and he's
got what four or five on Truth social uh
something like that his Die Hard
supporters are on Truth social his
ability to manipulate the Press is on
Twitter he said that because there's
there's the there's the a SPAC merger
involved he has to say that but I'm
telling you he has no choice but to go
back on Twitter agree and also January's
coming and Trump's two-year ban on meta
on Facebook on Instagram
that's over too baby so yeah the
two-year Timeout on Trump it's coming to
an end here yeah I think
and ready baby by the way though let's
let's and and far be it for me to you
know be the you know be the Debbie
Downer or whatever but
the regime's gonna strike back on Elon
yes they're already launching a probe
into him
they're going to go after SpaceX they're
going to go after starlink they're going
after Tesla they're going to come in and
say well you know we can't allow
remember and there was that that trial
balloon last week to say well the
cepheus we're going to look at your
funding the investment here so that and
then they pulled it away immediately
it's oh no that's not true that's not
actually happening that was a that was a
message that was a message to Elon and
it's not just the federal government
it's also big players like Bill Gates
that were organizing PR campaigns and
organizations and groups to pull money
from Twitter when Elon Musk would buy it
this was this was in the works uh Bill
Gates was planning to attack Twitter to
attack the advertisers to start a whole
PR campaign to try to bring Twitter down
specifically this was even admitted with
all of the money and all the influencing
yeah so right now Elon Musk he chopped
off the head of the snake he's the head
right now and I think there's going to
be people coming after it you know what
he should have done he should have
gotten like a a black cloak with a hood
and then put on roller roller skates or
rollerblades so that he would float
slowly into Twitter HQ looking and
pointing or fired just like and it would
be very demonic as he was that movie
where they came in with the paintball
gun oh yeah yeah it was uh no no it was
that suits that suits that show yeah
Entourage yeah the gel Blaster yeah
that's that's good I don't know about it
what I'm most excited about is the word
with with Twitter being bought by Elon
is we don't have to wait for any more
strongly worded letters from Lindsey
Graham about you know reigning in big
Tech you know because Elon just went out
and bought it but look that being he
said I and I'm just gonna say it right
this this is not you know the get rich
quick scheme this is not the magic wand
being waived and acting like all of the
fundamental problems and issues that
we've been talking about in this program
has been discussing for the last two
years they haven't magically gone away
because Elon did this this is a stopgap
measure at best right and those issues
are going to continue until the people
of this country actually come forward
put forward serious legislation on big
Tech and I think there still is a place
by the way for the forgetter for truth
social for rumble for all these I
certainly hope that Elon uh I think
based on what we've just seen this is
definitely a step in the right direction
for integration between
um uh Twitter and Rumble but at the same
time you can't just put all your eggs in
one basket you should never do that look
as as I'm sure as Ian would say if you
were here you know you never leave all
your stash in one place
absolutely and uh it's important to
understand here now I think we're
finally going to get some big Tech
regulations
I'm not saying this is why we have to be
careful about big Tech oligarchs oh yeah
suddenly yeah I mean the reason the the
censorship went crazy in the first place
is because you know a great uh Veterans
of the meme War 2016 like Jack you know
we use social media so effectively and
Luke and Luke again and and you know a
lot of people a lot of people who got
deleted you know well that's what I'm
talking about the pows of the great meme
War 2016 20 2015 2016 that once you let
those
riveting frogs return onto Twitter and
the social media platforms writ large
and just actually allow people to speak
freely and share information right a lot
of this goes back to the Wikileaks drops
in the fall of 2016 and the fact that
people were simply discussing the words
and phrases and contents of those
Wikileaks drops whether it be the DNC
emails the podesta emails Etc Hillary
Clinton stuff that came out that was why
they started turning the screws on
everybody else and claiming that oh you
made up this and no no no everybody was
reading the words of your own emails
that was from y'all that's exactly right
I just tweeted
groomer
can we dead name Rachel Levine well I
don't know YouTube is still owned by uh
yeah James like Jack now Carl Rove
can we say learn to code can we dead
name Karl Roof oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm gonna say that I'm doing learning
code we can do it together we can do it
together we'll tweet Karl Rove who by
the way complete Trader we've got we
could say it right now on the on the
live show people are just watching me
like post tweets
for the historical record
tell all the Twitter employees yeah what
should I tweet it's super chat
duper chat me what I should tweet frog
emojis looks like this is going to be so
interesting this is going to be so fun I
mean this is I I again I there's going
to be a lot of people going after for
for Elon his companies it's going to be
so fascinating to see how he's going to
navigate all these pressures
um I hope he has good people around him
I I hope he sticks to his guns I hope he
sticks to the basic principles of free
speech which I think he understands will
help out Humanity in such tremendous
ways because if you look at all the mess
that we're in right now it's
predominantly because of the lack of
information because of censorship
because of people controlling the
narratives and agenda it's it's because
of ignorance why these Elites and
bankers and multinational corporations
are able to get away with so much
travesty with so much Injustice and now
all of that could change in a moment
which just free speech with us just
being able to talk to each other Luke
are you saying we are change yes I could
have done a cheesy I did it before I
don't want to do it again
but this is this is an opportunity that
that is rare yeah and we got to take
advantage of it and we we as individuals
have to take it seriously this is kind
of amazing you know like Agarwal got
fired
and he already knows how to code
congratulations that's a good point yeah
we get you know who you know who really
also deserves to get fired um
all of those people that are making
those absolutely irritating tick tocks
of a day in them
and they all keep saying the word
obviously for some reason I know so uh
so obviously I just I came to work and I
obviously have made myself a caramel
macchiato and obviously I went to a
meeting and then obviously I had to take
a little rest because I went down to get
lunch and then obviously I went to go to
the roof for a little bit just catching
Vibes and then obviously we went out to
dinner and drinks and obviously it's the
word obviously and again 100 000 of
these videos by the way and I just put
it up guys you realize that tonight this
this actually is the October surprise
we're living through the October
surprise can we can we pull this one up
we have a tweet from Jack beso but
[Laughter]
we're still we're still on on YouTube so
I can't reveal all of my all of my memes
we'll share it later
yeah I just I'm just gonna let him keep
going you know while we're sitting here
that's that's pretty much it right there
the Frog happy Friday but you know what
you know that Matt Fury is doing Pepe
again right oh really so I thought Pepe
died
no no no he's completely done a 180 on
this because he found out about nfts
I'm serious you can go go if there's a
whole Washington Post article on this so
now he's like okay I want it so he's
like filthy rich now and is completely
leaned in on Pepe is making completely
and by the way not just memes but full
on animations of like a whole world of
Pepe and different Pepes Clan Pepe Nazi
Pepe no no no nothing like that
um like like Pepe doing karate and then
like an old Pepe watching him train and
then it goes into like Pepe's falling
through an hour hourglass and like
really trippy stuff there was like a
Darth he's worthless how many do you own
Jack not when he was doing them he's
done very very well for himself with
nfts how many do you own zero I don't
own any of these
um any promo codes for that one promo
code
um but the no he's done very very well
for himself and he just leaned in
totally leaned in on this and it's not
even it's not even political right it's
just Pepe
I'm dead naming Rachel Levine Karl Rove
no wait did we talk about what Karl Rove
is actually doing in Pennsylvania we did
not the snake what's he doing the snake
Alex you want to go for this what's that
neocon war Monger doing yeah so Karl
Rove the par part of the reason that the
Trump movement happened because of the
failed establishment GOP policies of
bush and Rove and all those losers uh
well he's now spending money against the
Republican gubernatorial candidate Doug
mastriano in Pennsylvania
and this is the principal conservative
that's spending money against
Republicans and it's completely
outrageous he's basically saying that
um
fetterman and mastriano are the same
people they're they're both too extreme
for Pennsylvania and uh none of the
Republican Consultants are upset with
this but all of the Republican
Consultants lashed out at Trump for
saying that he's not going to support a
closeted Democrat in Colorado named Joe
O'Day who's significantly overweight but
that's not even part of the point but
Karl Rove needs to be called out for
spending millions of dollars against
Doug mastriano so he what he's doing is
you've got people who donated to a
republican Super Pac and he's taking
Republican money and using it to support
a Democrat running for the governorship
of Pennsylvania along with Dr Oz so it's
a pro Dr Oz Pro Josh Shapiro ads that
are running on TV that are running on
the radio all across Pennsylvania and of
course by the way you know they they put
out the statement to the Philadelphia
Inquirer well for merely highlighting
the records of shut up yeah I mean do
you think we're stupid do you honestly
think we're stupid and so John Solomon's
call them out on this I've certainly
called them out you've called them out
we're done with the games we're
absolutely done with the games we know
what this guy Josh Shapiro has done to
the state we know the fact that he
didn't talk about who roles with Doug
mastriano let's talk about who rolls
with Dr Rachel Levine and the
experimentation the grabbing of homeless
children and children in the foster care
system and sticking them into gender
transition studies at the Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia AKA chop
there's also the uh I believe Rachel
Levine polled Doug when when the when
the excuse me when uh the elderly were
being killed by the governors who were
putting coveted patients in the nursing
homes Rachel Levine pulled their parents
out uh in advance so I think I think I
think it was obvious that many
government officials knew her own
parents yeah and put them in a hotel and
they knew what was going to happen with
uh in Pennsylvania and Michigan in
California and uh where's any
accountability for all those dead dead
people all those people who were killed
and you know the thing with Cuomo which
really just
you had the what was what was the boat
they had it wasn't the mercy the mercy
was the other one I think they had a
whole uh Naval uh hospital ship in yeah
in New York it wasn't the mercy I think
because I think people corrected us on
that one but they also the Javits Center
yeah and he didn't want to give Trump a
victory the Comfort the comfort and also
Central Park but also medical facilities
not a single bed was used and they
refused to use it yeah yeah they refused
to use it yeah because it would give
Trump a victory exactly we'll give you
if she's like yeah whatever you want
here's the Javits Center here's setting
up the entire U.S Navy
I am I am
it's it's all it's all it's all coming
back it's gonna be like 2017 all over it
again you know it's going to be the
memes it's going to be the crying Donald
Trump he's gonna it it's he's gonna post
we're gonna pop the champagne
you know
ladies and gentlemen we've got uh we got
a bottle of Louie in here I think maybe
this is an opportunity right now you
think right now right now
the head of the snake
[Applause]
you know how expensive this is we'll get
another one afterwards oh come on dude
look at Mr Penny bags over here I'm like
I'm like well you guys see a world end
Nick Frost no tap water for me
I mean
we the election's coming up right that
might be I don't know winning an
election is not like a Louis the 13th
month that's not going to matter as much
as this this is going to matter he
really wants a drink I don't want to
drink I will say this though you you
have to celebrate victories
that's the Slavic side in Utah
your victory in Poland we understand we
have to celebrate what we think yeah
can we can we yell at someone to bring
up five glasses is anybody watching Jim
cast tonight
literally yell someone just yell out the
door hey but yeah hey life is short it's
filled with a lot of crazy Journeys and
when when it's up you gotta appreciate
it right you gotta appreciate it because
if if you don't celebrate your victories
who will exactly right they're not going
to yeah right they're going to act like
this doesn't mean anything like it's not
a big deal like oh he's got the box
that's one to do the dude
that's perfect right where you are is
that is that a golden plaque yes I was
open from this way
wow don't drop it
I'll be a bad Omen like you're holding
that vicariously
Mr Mr Penny bags here understands not to
destroy think of value there it is the
button whoa
whoa wow look at that okay
whoa so this is uh unopened
and uh we had it for a celebration from
the 13th century folks if there if there
ever is a time this is it right someone
told me that's like really expect Grand
Champagne Cognac yeah I mean if it's
actually Louis XII but it's you guys
know which is this is several thousand
dollars wow it's like 200 bucks for an
ounce at a bar yeah it's one so it's uh
there you go so Luke
where the glasses at who went to go get
the glasses we're gonna have a clip to
last for the ages of us cracking open a
bottle of Louis XII to celebrate Elon
Musk firing the executives of Twitter
I'll go I'll go get the glasses I'll
take it
Luke's already are you all right bro
Luke why are you why are you getting
uh yeah give me a second here
we'll do a wide shot of us uh cheerzing
with a very very expensive I don't drink
yeah
we gotta have a sip yeah all right get
the good glasses
what is it what is this for the thing
yeah it's just so I can see it otherwise
I can't see it well who cares just pull
it up did you see the meme that I just
uh retweeted we're we're getting silly
with it I don't care what it looks like
oh I got glasses already oh look at this
to me and let's keep zooming
yeah it's fine hey thanks going that's
what I was telling you you can move it
around just use a little bit of 13
cognac 4 000. 500 4 500. for a bottle
this is the most expensive liquor and
then taxes Yeah Yeah by far the most
expensive
right how do you how do I open it I mean
first created in 1874. you probably have
like a little cork inside there that Joe
Biden was first selected
[Laughter]
so here's here's the here's the the
description first created in 1874 Louis
XIII cognac is an Exquisite blend of up
to 1200 grapes sourced 100 from Grand
champagne and matured slowly inside Oak
casks a rare artifact that is the life
achievement of generations of seller
Masters look at this wow look at this
fancy thing yeah so um a little watch I
went to uh when I was like a watch on
the inside
I ever had Louis was in was it was at
Trump Tower Tower bar in Chicago and
they had it up on the top and so I said
I would like to try that it was with
some friends and I was in Chicago people
I've I've known since I was a kid who
are good friends of Mines I hadn't seen
them in a long time and I said guys
we're going to do the best of the best
and when they pour it they actually have
like a little like a little butter knife
almost to make sure they don't miss a
single drop
and they really measured it out and made
sure it was all perfect we're not doing
that tonight I'm just just pouring a
little bit and uh no I'll make sure I
won't lose that drop there we go
all right jack there you go Jack
I will I'll give it a sniff no no just
do a little tiny a little bit not a tiny
bit no no no no no no how many years
Jack All For You 17 years
congratulations 17 years thank you oh
you don't you've never 17 years
figurative hey thanks man perhaps
okie doke I'm gonna put it to me now
that and by the way that was strong that
was I mean what was it stings the
nostrils at least get like some water I
got some like yeah
we got cheers no I don't want to Cheers
I don't want to Cheers give me something
there's like a hundred dollars right
here in this glass
I didn't I I knew I I got it to
celebrate we did this big crazy run
where we bought a bunch of really nice
moves it's for guests so you know we
have people here but this one was never
open this one was like
special and it's got to be for something
important but I think this this is I can
still smell it by the way yeah that's
how strong it is all right all right
there's a lot so free speech Free Speech
it's a free speech good enough I'm close
enough
yeah there we go all right ladies and
gentlemen Down the Hatch
you gotta enjoy it
don't just slam it you guys oh no I
didn't even have a shot I had like
barely half a shot just a little bit
that's actually remarkably good it is I
don't like I don't like drinking at all
I despise alcohol in every way but um
there's a reason why this is smells bad
it smells spicy it's good stuff cheers
everybody uh to the good days to the
victories
let's hope that's
November 8th is also another day worthy
of the Louis XII yeah and what appears
to be some that spilled oh no that's on
me
I will I will find an alternative to
venmo because they reinstate their
misinformation policy and then I will
pay you with that wow the uh just I just
happened to see this one delicious
Stephanie Guevara that was the Twitter
uh I guess iOS engineer it says senior
iOS engineer at Twitter who was who was
tweeting at Elon and like no she locked
her account oh man
on there that's just a tweet from Zero
Hedge uh how handsome is Hunter
you're saying he is he's a handsome guy
handsome guy
if you're into toothless crackheads wait
Tim do you see the meme I just posted
from uh from you just posted it right
now or what from mission is great from
Doug works by Doug when did you like uh
I just retweeted it
right now
um like a couple minutes ago
10 minutes ago 10 minutes ago how do I
find a random in feet wait was that it
nope that says Tim well click if you
click my account it'll go to it that is
correct if I if I go to your Twitter
scroll down right there
that's right I came on the show the
first time I think it was like three
years ago and I said it's going to be
memes that are going to save this
country no that's exactly right you know
I've made the heart everyone thought I
was crazy they're like memes this guy's
a joke what is this guy and I'm like
trust me before it happens you know
occasionally
four words make Twitter orange again
well I I have gotten some beef with some
congressmen and you know they go get the
media friends on their side or whatever
it is but I always have the memers on my
side yeah and I will go I'm able to run
fearlessly into battle knowing that they
have my back because the memers they
love this country yeah and quite frankly
they do more good for this country than
all of Canada they are our modern uh
Scholars they are the first rule of
infowar is whichever side has the
mimmers wins
the meme magic the mean magic yes yes
the mean magic it's evident that elon's
got all the meme magic yeah he's got me
magic on his side we'll see we'll see
where this goes I don't know if he's
Conjuring any Egyptian chaos Gods yeah
but well something we will go to super
chats now after our little celebrations
wondering is Delicious By the way it is
good it's really good you have to
celebrate your victories yeah absolutely
100 life is a huge cultural Victory
right there life is sure don't
this is more important than any election
in my opinion I agree yeah I agree if
you have freedom of speech you can then
you have the ability to fight back
exactly and you have the ability to hash
out and debate use your memes whatever
it is to defeat the other side and
actually argue your position for what's
better it equals the playing field
between the most powerful people in this
world and everyone else it is the
quintessential David versus Goliath
story if Trump had never won in 2016 the
censorship never would have existed no
it existed before Trump yeah it existed
very severely there's that internet
Theory no they they were realizing
that's fascinating by the way dead
internet so let's let's do this uh super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the share with
your friends become a member at
timcast.com go there click join us we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show after afterwards which I imagine
will be fun and spicy we're gonna be
dead naming so many people in there
that's right but for now we're gonna
down the bottle for now we are going to
read your super chats all right let's
see we got Xeno rabbit says will crypto
go up because of elon's Twitter deal it
already has doge is up 35 percent I
heard and um I hear ethereum is up
I don't know
not sure all right let's see we got here
not Danny McBride says I can't wait for
the new song Next Friday I'm gonna
pretend Tim wrote it for me since that
is my birthday yes we are releasing the
song
um it's called genocide it's really good
by the way it's funny because like a
bunch of bands have released songs that
are called genocide and they're very
like you know very serious but this is
actually kind of like a pop rock song it
reminds me of uh Muse does it really
I'm like no I I think it's it's like pop
rock
um with some Modern elements but you
know probably throw back a little bit
but uh we've got some special guests
that are going to be appearing in it
high profile media personalities I won't
name and uh they might sue us because of
it
uh we'll see what happens we stopped to
film it but we're working with a company
and uh I don't want to say too much but
uh the song is about uh the song is is
basically just about marching in
lockstep with the lies of the media that
bring us to war and famine and great
resets so I think people will like it's
so it's overtly political and the video
is going to be overtly political
I'm gonna be putting on my best Tucker
Carlson for this video oh yeah you're
going to want to see it people are
already posting the uh the wide shot of
all of us yeah hell yeah
I'm glad they're like these morons just
cracked open a five thousand dollar
bottle of cognac because Elon bought
Twitter that's right more geniuses
did you retweet it I want to retweet it
yeah I just did yeah all right just us
die he says hey Tim what do you think
about Saudi Arabia breaking ground on
the smart Mega City and if you uh and if
you get G Edward Griffin on I'll become
a member of timcast I I think the only
reason we didn't was because he's old
right
um I gotta reach out to him he would be
great I interviewed him a number of
times he's awesome super smart he wrote
the creature from Jekyll Island that's
right one of the smartest Minds we still
have out there I didn't realize she was
still around yeah yeah and he
interviewed Yuri bezumenov a lot of
people don't realize that he was the
other guy in that video interviewing him
no way yes and he's the one who wrote
creature from Jekyll Island
yeah he's been around for a while so
just don't say anything I'm showing you
this yet
oh yeah oh yeah just for those that are
listening I just got a text message from
someone responding and it's just it's
it's a good the texts are flying folks
attacks are flying my my family my dad
just opened his motion bunch of
champagne that's what he says in the
chat I got a text if you're out there
let me just say that right that this
celebration if if you're within the
sound of our voices right now celebrate
tonight whoever you're with grab your
best friend please do please do there's
gonna be like tonight is a night of
Celebration tonight this is a
celebratory night so there's going to be
some woman she's like sitting on her
couch and she's watching you know I
don't know what do they want the Watcher
or something and then her husband's
gonna run over and go honey and she's
gonna go yeah and he's gonna pick her up
and he's gonna give her this passionate
kiss it's gonna be like what's the
occasion there's gonna be a few fired
there's gonna be so many of the babies
made tonight we're gonna be making
babies all night folks the Tim cast Baby
Boom so it's gonna be it's gonna name
the baby Twitter around July we see a
weird spike in all these babies right
like what could it be why are they all
named Twitter yeah
just the uh just the uh the stock twtr
all right DJ Cod Gill says Tim your
knowledge on the Civil War is cringe
inducing every time you blank there's
nothing there just every time you space
uh get Thomas D Lorenzo Ryan Dawson and
his brother Scott or even razor fist on
to give you the other side of the story
other side the pro Union side is it I
don't understand
is that the point you were making
because because I was talking the other
day about there were four states North
Carolina Tennessee Arkansas and Virginia
that did not initially secede and then
it was only after Lincoln called for 75
000 troops to suppress the South that
they decided to actually join the
Confederacy so I guess the other side of
that is why the union decided to invade
or whatever no I mean that literally I
mean I I don't think I know everything
with Civil War I think I I read a few
academic papers the other day
anyway we'll read some more graft he
says finally buck buck I had video that
was recently fed to me about Tim that
was hilarious to watch the Twitter game
really affects some was it about my
tweets I love how like you know
basically all of my tweets are insane
right you know I said Elon Musk should
make a new verification except it just
shows that you're a fascist and it's red
yeah and it's just like I wonder if
these leftists actually follow my tweets
and think they're real and I have to
imagine they do yeah no doubt yeah
you know you the the people have this
thing called Google IQ now is kind of
what I call it and it's this idea that
you know I mean you look at some of
these books that gets written on any
subject and it's always just sort of
like a compilation of the top five
Google search hits and there's no actual
research there's no actual work there's
no primary source research done
interviews anything like that and then
people will say oh I can just Google
something and therefore I know
everything about that subject and it is
it is probably the biggest danger in
society today which is why this Twitter
situation is so huge because you've got
an ability now he can actually break the
echo Chambers people will be able to see
Truth For the First Time Ever we gotta
we got a major fact check here Alex just
be shamed of yourself
dream cream says the Pokemon movie scene
happened the other way Ash turned to
stone get out of here and it was the
Pokemon right now
spit that Louie out I'm not sorry spit
it out then you spilled it I I haven't
seen that movie in in many years but but
now it makes sense you guys are right
yeah
um and now the analogy doesn't work it's
like the only show where you'd get fact
check on that yeah
all right Matthew Hammond says have you
asked why advertising agencies overlap
with Democrat voters on Twitter
Anheuser-Busch was acquired by inbev in
2008 in 2014 they moved considerable ad
spending from St Louis firms to New York
City firms and set the stage for the
centralization of woke advertising uh
study was done that mapped cultures and
like communities on Twitter and they
found that digital marketing and liberal
voters was basically the same block
so that's what Dave Portnoy is trying to
do now what is that well I mean it's
it's so Dave portno is doing this whole
thing where he's trying to say that okay
I'm I'm more masculine but I'm also in
terms of you know Sports and drinking
but that's the only kind of masculinity
that is allowed and betting obviously
because that's where he makes his money
but then uh in terms of a of every
single political issue possible he's as
liberal as they come whether it be
abortion right whether it be sense any
of this stuff true well with all these
companies going woke I think Barstool
conservatives like I think it's
important that we start you saw Alta had
two men talking about beauty products
recently all of these companies are
going woke right now and there's an
awesome company called Public Square
public SQL and they are fighting back
like we've never seen before against the
world corporations it's uh it's
basically connecting pro-america
consumers with pro-america businesses
tens of thousands of pro-america
companies are on the platform hundreds
of thousands of users and so I strongly
suggest you guys go to publicesq.com get
involved and fight back are we we are
big fans are we allowed to talk about
what Public Square has planned for their
next phrase or is that not public yeah
well
you know well it's just well they're
they're kind of like they're kind of
like a directory right now but they have
plans it's Public Public Square is
businesses that have this pledge where
they support American values it's
amazing you open up them open up the app
you look at the map and you can find
businesses near you that agree with
American values like the Constitution
for instance and then you can choose to
give them your money let's read more we
got kalishnikov he says Tim can we
please hear you say Roe v Wade John
fetterman style wrote v Wade
wrote v wait I support row v Wade
because the weird thing was that he kept
saying the exact same way every time
as rule
let's see what we got here in the old
super jets
waffle Sensei says when Elon fires
everyone an employee starts screaming
and crying he should simply lay a hand
on their shoulder look them straight in
the eye with a loving smile and say
learn to do real work
wait you there was a thing that Zero
Hedge tweeted now I wasn't sure if it
was a true quote or not where he was
talking about remote work and he said
Twitter employees are free to to work
from home as much as they want just not
from Twitter
I was like was that a real quarter I
mean I choose to believe that's real as
as as Steve Bannon likes to say too too
good to check this is good this is good
kylo Wolff says Elon Musk should bring
Trump back to Twitter so long as his
first post is a video reading off the
name of every employee musk's cutting
from Twitter followed by you're fired or
how about Elon bring Trump in to go up
to the people you're fighting and go
you're fired I just I mean no no but
then also charge pay-per-view for it and
you'd instantly make Twitter profitable
there you go overnight who needs
advertising right through through Rumble
by them other news Twitter generates 736
billion dollars in one night
Jim
all right legumoth again says fetterman
said he supports and doesn't support
fracking literally in the same breath in
the future the sympathetic media and
Orthodox leftists will pair whichever
position is most advantageous in the
moment and anyone who points out the
flip-flop will be an other
have you guys watched kill all others
from on on Amazon yet no you need to
watch it Jack Amazon Prime I know we all
Amazon sucks but electric dreams is the
show okay it's an anthology series and I
think the last episode is called kill
all others and you need to watch it you
it is a must must must watch people
who've listened to the show and watched
it know exactly what I'm talking about
people who didn't you don't understand
you have to what you have to yeah people
in the chat like said earlier there's
like a prediction of the future it was
it's prophetic but it's also a great
commentary the gist of it is this
regular old factory worker guy bumbles
about comes home turns on the political
inner political interview with the
mainstream candidate and they're like so
what are you hoping to do and the
woman's like well you look I wanna I
wanna uh bolster education I want to get
inflation on track I want to kill all
others of course and I want to make sure
the working class in this country know
that I'm here for them and then he goes
what did she just say and then he's like
he plays it and then he's like he's like
honey listen to this the the interviewer
is going to get the candidate and then
the interviewer goes now that's
controversial education I mean a lot of
people and so basically what happens is
there's another scene where he sees a
woman screaming and running and people
are chasing after beating the crap out
of her and he's another because she's
another and then they were like why are
you defending her are you an other and
he's like no I just stop attack and then
it escalates from there and you can
imagine what the episode is yeah it's
really good and I was my mind was blown
when I watched it I was like damn
because it's like no but Tim that's so
confusing because there's nothing like
that going on in the real world you saw
Susan Sarandon right yeah when she was
basically like Democrats are bad and it
was like she she made this post where it
was like well I'm sure in her mind she
didn't think it was Democrats no of
course but it's not Republicans it said
when like they're censoring speech and
getting violent that's when you know
things are getting bad or something and
it's like that's that's clearly
Democrats like if you're raiding the
political opposition locking them up
taking them off of the Public Square
um you know that's clear they're
smearing them throughout the internet
Etc I just got a text from one of our
fallen heroes the great Carpe Duncan yes
and uh I just want to say that he will
be back on Twitter how does he know he
will be back and he'll be back better
than ever before but he said he's got my
back because I was talking about but is
he is he saying he intends to fully
fully utilize Twitter or has he been
given a promise or uh no he said he's
got my back but I'm telling you right
now Carpe is going to be back and he's
gonna be back with vengeance and the
memes are gonna be phenomenal he
actually texted me as well and he he
just sent me a picture of vijaya's um
Twitter bio and he highlighted the part
where she said legal policy and Trust
lead at Twitter and then he wrote
permanent suspension for misinformation
carpet Carpe is the man we need him back
desperately of course and uh
come back soon Carpe actually a lot of
people no way a lot of people are
tweeting that about the Giant now oh
yeah all right let's see what we got
here what is this one
Crooked Smile says any chance we could
get Ian to dress and act like Sheamus
for an episode on cast Castle to lure
Sheamus out of hiding he just abandoned
us you know we also got Alex I'm getting
all these texts from these fallen heroes
Alex the Lord
uh he said he's gonna be back soon
we will rise
a lot
what do you send me
uh no you just so it's the Lord I would
like to be I'd like to be on the planet
many people are tweeting the orange
Emoji right now like the orange fruit
yes exactly Trump what I'm saying is we
need some confirmation that the move's
gonna happen agreed we need them back
hurry up you Lord all right John R says
on the Joe Rogan podcast Vijaya
pronounced her name video hmm
good so I apologize for mispronouncing
your name video no that's not as fun as
to say all right here we go this guy is
more fun Liberty Bell says Jack get
mastriano to send teams to pit Philly
and A-Town Hispanic and black families
are conservative show them what Shapiro
will do with education and his crime
enabling policies PA is key to mid-class
energy and Northeast I mean Josh Shapiro
just wants to be president he doesn't
care about how many pennsylvanians have
to die between him and the White House
and that's really all it comes down to
everyone started posting oranges in the
chat amen bring him back throw them up
folks throw them up throw them up Eeyore
says hey Tim saw your morning segment
about Twitter I'm glad the majority of
them are being fired I believe everyone
should endure hard labor in life maybe
they'll learn to have thicker skin with
calluses on their hands do you guys see
that day in the life of a Twitter
employee video that went viral yeah yeah
that's what I was talking about yeah I
just just obviously
these are the people who are like you're
being really mean and we need to be on
you uh Elon you got to fire them you
really do or make them go work in like
the boiler room tonight what do we even
do tonight the Streets Run Orange
[Laughter]
all right
Let's uh let's grab some good uh Super
Chips by orange I mean Donald Trump the
45th president of the United States by
the way hey you guys can't you guys
can't see the chat but there's literally
oranges like the entire way down yeah
orange Lord orange Lord orange man good
orange man good there once was a man who
went around the country
warning us of censorship warning us of
illegals warning us of rapists coming
across the border and the people hated
him and so they threw him away
but some say one day
El naranya May return
[Laughter]
all right Nick Williams says I think
musk pushed off the purchase until after
the global recession because most of the
leftists funding sources are now tied up
in trading down
I'm not sure I understand
I guess because because Twitter and era
Facebook and and Amazon I think that's a
little too on the money I don't know if
he could have timed that
let's grab another Super Chat we got a
bunch here there let's see
what do we got oh it's a lot of people
saying to drink the Louie we did we did
uh alitza right now says James O'Keefe
and Carpe dongtum can return we are
hoping that and I assume it will be the
case but I I think you may be right we
need some kind of mass amnesty I think
the first thing they can do immediately
is anybody who was verified is instantly
reinstated and then after that
anybody who was uh like I I think verify
probably should be the threshold but
it's like anybody banned under the
criteria of political speech like a hate
speech rule yeah anyone banned for a
legal activity and flagged I don't care
if they stay banned or misinformed if it
was misinformation and if it was one of
these things
um or by the way why not also
some sort of appeals process for hey you
know I was banned under these weird
multiple accounts rules kind of things
because as much as I want James O'Keefe
and Alx and Carpe and all these great
people back imagine the people out there
with 50 followers 100 25 followers 100
followers that plugged away every day
that retweeted stuff that use the promo
code what about them yeah somebody
actually has to make sure that those
people come back and so that's why I say
General after January 6 hundreds of
thousands of the people you're just
talking about now completely they were
all removed and they don't have an
access to the Town Square they can have
a conversation they can't that's so
wrong and so uh you're exactly right
with what you just said there Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Tim that was a nice
moment always move forward and uh we'll
have clips of that you know the little
image of us cheersing the uh the Louis
XII it's already going viral oh is it
yeah let me pull up my uh people are
people screenshotted it and it's already
kind of like a thing let me uh you
retweeted it yeah I'll retweet it let me
let me pull it up no we should drink
orange juice I'll drink orange juice I'm
not drinking the Kool-Aid
[Laughter]
[Music]
posobic serves Kool-Aid on teamcast
all right I'm tweeting real quick
spiked with oranges
there's no any good ones surge in there
that you you see super chats that you
want to address and bring up right now
uh cheers Tim and crew I'm raising my
glass with you guys doing it on my
social media accounts except for this
but I will be signing up on Twitter now
we're going to have that members only
show that's a huge point A lot of people
are going to flood into Twitter now I'm
going to invest in that platform more
than any other platform right now wow
well it so uh are we able to talk about
the rumors or should we are we not I
don't know about what Elon may do did we
already talk about those or what's going
on well I know we've talked about
General honesty I know he's talking
about bringing Trump back no I'm talking
about like with other companies
uh the rumble stuff oh okay well there
you go you said it so what's the deal
yeah I mean the deal the rumor is either
a straight up integration slash
partnership or possibly
if he looks at the numbers and if he
feels like doing it maybe even a
wholesale acquisition
that's been the big rumor crushing it
they have a 78 million daily active
users yeah it's huge it's insane oh yeah
we have a couple hundred thousand Subs
on on this channel than my other channel
Yeah Yeah we actually get a decent
amount of views it's a great leadership
we can win more on YouTube uh wreck he
had a law is killing it on Rumble yes
and abandoned War Room War Room
obviously yeah if if Jack does a deal
I'm sorry if Elon does a deal with uh
Jack Dorsey if Elon does a deal with
Rumble then all of a sudden people who
have built these Twitter followings now
have a video platform alongside it with
potential for monetization it's going to
instantly make something substantially
it's the only platform that doesn't
actually provide monetization to its
most most engaged and uh highest
follower account users it's just every
single other one has this yeah I mean
they've they've tried the super follow
right where where you're like basically
paying to endure some given yeah but
nobody does they will try every
everything other than actually just
directly yeah uh supporting people it
super follows they tried this ridiculous
communities tab that nobody likes right
spaces which is definitely fire the
bloat killed Periscope by the way yeah
for me so stupid you need if you bring
in Rumble you have to sit down and take
that original Periscope code put that up
because I believe Twitter still owns
that so take that code give it to rumble
integrate Rumble with a wave right for
me to just be able to go all I want to
do is go live on Twitter yep that's all
we wanted to ever do yeah we used to get
millions on these things there's a live
but it's it's terrible right it's hard
full Wi-Fi and it looks like potato it's
a total potato level I can't believe
that vine Sheamus would like that vine
may do it make celebrities Vine was huge
and Twitter was like shut it down yeah
he's fine no they killed Periscope
because it was like me and cernovich
were the ones that were getting the most
views on it
well maybe uh with Elon they'll learn
their lesson man A lot of people are
saying Laura Loomer over and over again
uh I really do look forward uh Laura
you're back and um maybe maybe there's
something she can do she can like when
she gets invited to Twitter she'll be
wearing a handcuff on one wrist as she's
shaking the hands of the people but then
she'll be the one escorting people out
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com because we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show and there's a lot more to say we've
got a couple other stories we want to
talk about so we'll have that over at
timcast.com for you you can follow us at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
Alex you want to shout anything out uh
follow me at Alex bruzowitz uh my name's
spelled in the caption uh and get out to
vote flood the polls watch the polls we
need to make sure that we have a red
wave on November 8th because we have a
country to save my friends Elon played
his part you do yours on on November 8th
uh yeah Jack wasobik host of human
events daily real America's voice also
on the podcast side 25 minutes a day our
motto our oath our solemn vow be good be
brief be gone to everybody 25 minutes or
less Libby Emmons has been co-hosting
some episodes this week so a lot a lot
of uh a lot of fun there more
conversational and I'm gonna be in
Pennsylvania for the next couple of days
um campaigning with Doug mastriano gonna
be at the Trump rally with Dr Oz and
mastriano here in Latrobe and then I
will be headed to Phoenix for the
election but remember folks we have 12
Days 12 days left to save the Republic
and so I know there's going to be a lot
of sleepless nights out there but if
you're having trouble sleeping in the
night
anxious about Elon Musk taking over
Twitter and potentially losing your job
Vijaya
it's simple
promo code Pozo at mypillow.com is still
available to you Vijaya I know it's
going to be rough tonight you're going
to need a quality pillow to sleep on
my YouTube channel is youtube.com
forward slash we are change I did a very
interesting video today about Elon Musk
Vladimir Putin and his new world order
comments it's a very interesting video
I'm very proud of it and you could watch
it right now on youtube.com forward
slash we are change see you there and
now that Twitter is South African named
everyone can see this is kind of a big
view right now now that it's South
African owned I will be getting a
Twitter I have a Twitter it's African
yeah so that's going on uh it is surge
with African-American businesses yeah
support African-American businesses
thanks guys you can really see in the
why chat how messy this room is I know I
know we're gonna get a better one guys
it'll it'll happen well we're building
the new space we got a big a bunch of
stuff we're filming the music video for
the new song this weekend some of it's
already being produced with CGI and then
we're also filming the car contest so
it's gonna be really really fun so head
over to timcast.com become a member
thanks for hanging out everybody and
we'll see y'all there cheers
I don't get it no I said gaze for Trump
oh gays yeah that's who tweeted we're
still alive